欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,前面我们已经讲了怎么样去确定你的产品的词根
第二个讲了如何进行有效的关键词分类
第三个我们来讲一下我们要怎么样去选词
选到更加精准的一些词
让我们后期的一个推广更加省钱
首先我们选词通常是在搜索指数
这个板块进行一个选词的
把我们的词根放到搜索栏
然后选择时间一定要选择近30天
最低最低你要选择7天
这样的数据才更加有效
终端的话全部全球的话也是全部
因为这样的话全部的话
你能够把这个词所拓展出的总的相关的词就更多
也就是这个板块的词就会非常非常的多
那么它的标准我们怎么样去看呢
第一个就是它的一个
搜索指数
够不够大
由高向低
降续排
我们看到点击率是不是有点击率存在的
买家卖家规模
大不大
如果是
大的
那么说明它的竞争是非常大的
那么我们建议先优先选择
搜索指数大
点击率高
卖家规模指数
小的词
这个是大
这个是
高的
点击率是高的
这个是
小的
我们就按照这个逻辑去选优先选择这些词去组合标题
或者是说
去进行一个推广
优先这些词
我们具体到后台看一下
比如说我搜索某一个关键词
我就随便按照一个词来说
比如说位移我收了之后
我是不是这里选30天
然后这些全部不选
那么下面出来的这些都是跟位移这个词根是相关的
所有的相关词
这些词我们都可以把它导出来
整理到表格中
我们把不相关的这些词
不相关的在表格中删掉
我们组合标题的话优先使用哪些呢
我们组合标题优先使用
搜索指数大的
点击率高的
卖家规模
小的
按照这种逻辑去先选
选这些词先优先使用
一定要优先使用这些词
点击率是不是有些点击率是零的
是零的点击率,零的点击率
这种词的话
我们在推广的时候
不要推,不要推广这类词
这类词会导致
高点击
低转化
这已经测试过很多了
大部分行业都会出现这种情况
所以说你们行业很有可能也是这样
如果你不信
你可以去看你的自动车
现在高点击的词
或者是
后期持续的关注
如果出现高点击的词
没有什么循环的你来把词拿到关键词指数搜索一下
看看它的一个点击率怎么样
你可以看7天的也可以看30天的点击率
看看它是怎么样的
你就会慢慢的发现规律了
接着呢
比如说你想要
知道你的美国的
客户都是搜索哪些跟这个相关的词比较多
比如说我在这里选
美国找到美国
英国找到美国了
美国搜一下
也就是你当你确定了这个
地区之后
这边的话这个词跟
出现的下面这些词
都是跟美国搜索量相关度比较高的那些词就会出现了
比如说你想
做美国市场是吧
你就去
主打某一款A产品你想主打美国那么你就
通过这些词根去把这些词
搜索出来
用这些词去
组A的标题
A的标题T
A的关键词K1
K2
K3
你就从
锁定的这些词去找
那么后期呢
你推广的时候也优先推广
跟这些
跟A这个产品相关的
标题
还有关键词
优先推广你选的这些词
因为这些词都是美国偏好的所以说你推广的话
能够精准性
会更加大
而且他的转化很有可能更高
你千万不要
做美国市场用了大量的非洲的那些
偏好的关键词去发产品去推产品
如果你直动车没有达到要3到要4的时候
你就用这些非洲的这些
偏好的
产品持续推的话那么你来的流量大概率也是非洲的就会导致你这个产品
转化非常低
很有可能就是只有
点击
没有询盘没有DM
订单更加没有
所以说一定要注意这个
逻辑
你的目标是基于如何去获取高质量询盘
去做这些标题和做推广的
不要随意的去
用那些
不相关的或者是相关度低的那些持续推广
你要去推广就一定要
认真的去做好标题跟KKK3
这样的话你的成功概率就会更大
所以说
推广他都是遵从一定的逻辑的并不是说
凭感觉
而是基于数据跟基于你对这个关键词的
效果判断
去有效的推广
那么这个就是关于选词的
一个方面
第2个呢
这些关联词
比如说你觉得
有些行业
是不是比较冷门
你就找的词感觉
好像搜索指数也不多
总的词量也不多
那么你就可以在这些地方去看一下
去拓展这些词
关联词怎么去拓展呢
比如说
这个词是词根
跟这个相关的
那么你就把这个词
复制出来
然后打开新的一个
关键词指数
去搜它
搜索
你把这些
去找到它就可以了
你看这个就是跟这个相关的
你就
在看这里面的这些
这些
哪些是跟你相关的
这些哪些是跟你相关的
你还是按照我刚才说的那个直接去搜索指数里面去
进行对这些搜索搜索了然后去
里面选择那些适合你的词就可以了
不适合的
不要
只有适合的
就挑选出来
放到表格
挑它出来
这些
都是可以进行跟那个刚才那个逻辑是一样的
因为这些看的话有些词我们是不是会遗漏
遗漏的话那我们就在这里查漏股权
还有另一个我讲一个
逻辑
比如说你
收的某个词
这里是收比如说我收这个词
如果你是做美国市场的
这里刚好出现美国是不是
比较
符合
那么就这个词就可以用
这个A关键词就可以用
如果你做的是
呃非洲的市场
你收出这个A这个关键词发现
好像这里
没有非洲的是吧
那么没有非洲是不是这个词就在
非洲的流量就会
少因为他本身搜索
非洲人收的这些
词就少所以说他的流量就少
那么你获取流量的
难度就大因为本身就没有没有人收
所以说你要去找
那些指数
多的
那些指
用在对应的国家
那么你的流量
就会更大了
流量大
最后我们来讲一个就是
如果你收出的这个A关键词
比如说他的这个端口WAP
占比非常高的
比如说他占比高于50
50%
或者是40到50%的时候
那么这类词你就少少用
因为这个端口的话
他的询盘转化
非常低的
为什么这个基本都是一些
没有注册阿里买家的
这些
商家去使用的或者是个人去使用的也有可能是阿里的
一些乍卖广告投放给
这些
买家他看到了去点击
所以说这可能就会导致高点击但是呢他的询盘转化很低
即使有询盘很可能就是
不回复你的
那些询盘
都是未读的询盘
基本就是这种类型
的词带来的
占比大的那些词带来的
所以说你一定要去认真的去分析这些去选择
平时你做产品优化
子龙车推广的时候
也要来这里看一下
你推广那个词
当前的一个
国家地区分布是怎么样的
搜索指数
还有他的
分端占比是怎么样的
这样更有利于你去判断这个词的一个价值
还值不值得你推
因为你可能是花了一些
钱在这个词上面
数据积累了一定的
程度不想不舍得放弃
不舍得放弃
你就来这里判断一下
他还值不值得你推就可以了
那么这个就是关于
我们如何去选词的一个
方式方法
我们最好
开始结合着自己的行业
去开始进行一个
选词做好表格
把它归类
分好
因为你只要你做好了一次
这个表格的后期你就不断的迭代更新你这个表格就可以了
那么你这相当于你的
一个词库就完整了
那么你每个品类的词库就完整了
后面你所做的工作都是围绕着这些
内容来做
你的工作会更加轻松
就不至于你每次都是
从头开始
每次都从头开始
那么你的
工作量就很多
而且你也
没有什么方向去把握这些词
如果你有了词库
然后做好了记录
那么你每一项工作
都是在
正向的积累
那么你的后面的工作就会越来越轻松
好了这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再讲其他板块的内容